hey buddy miss you you should know each
other you guys know each other no no no
okay say you like V white dude yeah yeah
yeah he's gonna drop off a resume to
charge job they don't yeah you always
hear about the man that's the man right
there holding us down buddy that's a man
oh man I'm just commenting on how white
he looks um how you guys all see him
uncomfortable that it he not boner
yeah he's translucent yeah we could see
his heartbeat in there he's like he cut
his hair with have you met the parents
you've not that she has not even told ya
oh my god
[Applause]
but her parents don't even know she
dates yeah Ryan are you seeing anyone
no mummy nobody you can't even see him
he comes over for dinner because a ghost
in the house so what's the plan
wait till they get engaged that's the
plan cuz we know his side doesn't give a
[ __ ] she's she's uh really damn Wow that
spray tan how long how long has this
been going on nine months what a website
what dating up bar huh a bar
I haven't downloaded that one son nice
nice is this is this the first time I
meet absolutely you're Indian is the
first time you're getting an Indian
person what that's good I mean I hate
you a little bit but yeah
I've never done it I don't know what
it's like really I know what do you do
for a living
consulting right right I can't I feel
like the only got into consulting to
date an Indian woman that's he just went
where they were you know I mean that's
how I grow I used to do how long has it
been none yeah what was the race of the
last girl you dated what was the race of
the life he just gave you attitude this
he said this is a third time he said in
nine months and he got upset yeah yeah I
swear to god this how he got upset nine
months third time you're not ready for
an Indian girl them do that docile yeah
sitting here giving this [ __ ] pranaam
every time you get a job have you guys
got into a fight yet right now no fights
you know there's no fights
he's [ __ ] in the corner just shaking
this whole day is a celebration of a
breakup you realize it yeah yeah I'm who
you left you guys
that one get a little too close Yeah
right little too everyone got a little
weird on that I agree all right